[Musique]
Olivier roche bonjour bonjour on est on
est au golf national on est derrière une
une sculpture duuber privé hein c'est ça
ouais exact exact fait des sculpures
magnifiques avec avec des objets de golf
là c'est c'est des on est dans golf
national dont dont vous êtes le
directeur un mot d'abord sur sur ce ce
golf national qui va connaître
évidemment la rider COV en 2018 mais ça
on aura le temps d'en parler il a été
construit en quand à peu près là les
premiers plans sont sortis en 85 et puis
le le la construction a commencé 88 89
et on a inauguré en 90 donc ça allit
relativement vite pour un parcours de de
140 hactares il y a 45 trous donc ça a
été des gros travaux très longs mais
très bien menés et donc en 2 ans et demi
le golf est est sorti de terre est sorti
de terre avec trois parcours don don
celui sur lequel on est qui qui est
l'Albatros qui est qui était tout
nouveau en France puisque'au fond c'est
un stade de de de golf quoi ouais alors
on est sur un un stade atypique de golf
une grande nouveauté on a mis le centre
du jeu où les fairway les Green au
milieu du jeu et on a construit autour
des grandes butes qui permettent de voir
le spectacle donc c'est typique dans le
sens voilà dénivel comme ça des dénivelé
très important totalement construit hein
il y a il y a rien de naturel euh pour
permettre spectacle et au spectateurs
d'en profiter donc un spectacle
extraordinaire on le voit mieux et des
spectateurs
autour la dimension qu'on a voulu y
donner et dès les années 85 c'était de
de pouvoir rendre médiatique
populaire voilà un spectacle de mettre
en scène ce spectacle alors que si on
connaît d'autres parcours qui sont soit
boisés soit vallonnés mais pas simple
d'accès bah forcément les spectateurs
peuvent pas beaucoup voir ou voir un
coup ou 200 m de de de de vision mais ne
voit pas plus là à l'endroit où on est
on est donc sur un sur un site où on
voit quatre trous en même temps et c'est
extraordinaire parce qu' en plus il y a
du spectacle et tout a été fait dans cet
esprit et c'est vraiment là pour pour le
coup très très novateur alors il y a il
y a évidemment beaucoup de compétitions
dont dont la compétition reen si je puis
dire ici c'est c'est l' P de France et
alors là on voit on voit que il y a des
travaux je pense qu'on prépare là il va
il va venir c'est quand au mois de juin
oui alors c'est c'est c'est fin juin
première semaine de juillet et
effectivement on est vraiment dans les
préparations la difficulté bah c'est
toujours de coordonner les événements un
petit peu exceptionnels et la vie au
quotidien donc voilà là pendant une
semaine le golf il est fermé ou tout du
moins ce parcours est fermé parcours oui
par de autes voilà les deux autres sont
ouverts et tous les licenciés de la
Fédération peuvent en profiter mais
celui-ci est fermé bichonné évidemment
parce que les meilleurs joueurs du monde
vont venir d'ici 4 mois et c'est
beaucoup beaucoup de préparatifs sur le
parcours pour leur donner la meilleure
qualité possible alors il y a eu ce qui
était assez rare au fond en France mais
depuis que ça se ça se déroule le golf
national il y a eu quand même trois
victoires françaises dans cette open il
me semble en deux fois remésieouou ouais
un open un open national dans l'esprit
très important pour nos Français et
rarement gagné oui c'est rare hein très
rare alors il y a quelques espagnols qui
gagnent en Espagne rarement des Italiens
en Italie enfin et effectivement quand
on discute avec avec les les pro
français ben ils subissent une pression
importante parce que voilà il y a il y a
plus de de familles il y a plus de de
personnes qui les connaissent qui les
encouragent et c'est pas quelque chose
sur sur sur lequel ils ont ils ont
vraiment l'habitude de travailler donc
ils arrivici avec beaucoup de pression
et donc il est rare qu' françaisê me il
veulent être le meilleurs poss possible
ils veulent briller il y en a comme
comme Raphael Jacquelin ou grégoryi AVR
qui vivent à l'étranger très très bien
sur les sur les
tournois et quand ils arrivent ici ouais
ils sont un petit peu scérosé ils ont
ils ont du mal à s'exprimer parce que
c'est chez eux parce qu'il y a beaucoup
plus d'amis parce que grégoryie Avre il
est de bu George qui est est pas loin
donc forcément il y a 300 personnes qui
arrivent qui le suivent et ce ce petit
côté supplémentaire comme ils le vivent
pas au quotidien ils ont un peu de mal à
le gérer mais mais là on a un tonant du
titre et là on a un tonant du titre
Thomas Thomas Levet qui a joué la rider
Cup qui l'a gagné donc c'est vrai que
c'tait même un retour quoi sur cetteire
l'année dernière
par c'est c'est une très très belle
histoire et bah ça a inscrit un nom au
palmarès et trois Français sur les 10
dernières années ça démontre aussi le le
bon le bon niveau de nos Français al
qu'est-ce qui s'est fait il a sauté dans
le dans la rivière ouais alors ils ont
fait ils ont fait ils ont fait un petit
Paris enfin bon voilà ils sont tous
fiers il y a le champagne c'est
traditionnel maintenant et ils ont
saenté dans l'eau je leuris recommandé
de pas sauter exactement à cet
endroit-là parce que on sait que selon
nos constructions il y a des endroits où
on voilà plus ou moins profond et euh
quand je leur ai dit surtout vous ne
sautez pas là ils ont entendu dans
l'euphorie surtout sauz là ah la vache
c'est votre route VO oui forcément c'est
de ma faute forcément donc plus
sérieusement oui il s il s'est fait un
beau petit bobo ou il s'est fait un beau
petit bobo euh après euh comme grand
comme grand champion euh il nous a dit
bah moi je suis fier d'être blessé parce
que j'ai gagné l'Open et si j'avais pas
gagner Leop je me serai pas blessé et je
préfère me blesser et gagner le open
donc c'est le bon champion qui arrive à
le retourner médiatiquement c'est pas
top qu'un enfant qu'un gagnant un
vainqueur se blesse et bon c'est la vie
et puis c'est pas très professionnel de
jeter de se jeter dans l'eau enfin al il
f il fera peut-être attention cette
année s'il jamais les autres aussi p
jamais il gagne alors vous êtes le le
directeur de de de de ce golf c'est quoi
ça consist quoi le rôle d' directeur de
golf il évidemment voilà les grandes
compétitions mais il y a aussi tous les
licenciés qui peuvent venir oui alors ce
golf est atypique il a il appartient à
la Fédération Française de Golf donc
c'est un outil fédéral tout autre golf
appartient soit une association sportive
ou une société commerciale donc on a des
enjeux et des objectifs différents celui
du Golf National il doit répondre à à à
un grand nombre de d'objectifs tant
fédéral donc l'outil fédéral recevoir
ici on reçoit un pôle France un pôle
espoir donc c'est des jeunes qui
s'entraînent donc on le on doit leur
donner des conditions de de jeu euh de
très haut niveau bien s forcément on a
évidemment nos licenciés c'est une des
particularités de d'une fédération
d'avoir un outil fédéral qui est ouvert
au licencier donc bah on essaie d'allier
euh bah l'accueil du public euh notre
sport de haut niveau amateur les
meilleurs pros qui viennent s'entraîner
et puis après la préparation pour
l'Albatros mais il y a que l'Albatros de
ce parcours élitiste exceptionnel qui
nous a permis au fil des années bah de
d'améliorer la qualité et de pouvoir
prétendre à au moins être candidat à la
rider Cup parce que pour être candidat à
la rider Cup il faut aussi un très très
bon parcours très bon parcours c'était
c'était un métier ou une fonction je
sais pas comment on dit que vous rêviez
d'occuper non pas forcment vous êt c'est
un peu un hasard un hasard c'est une
suite logique je dirais de management
euh moi j'ai toujours été salarié de la
Fédération je suis depuis plus de 20 ans
la f Le c'est une passion alors ah voilà
le golf est une passion notre métier
mais comme tout métier vraiment dans
dans dans le golf est un métier passion
comme d'autres d'autres métiers et moi
j'ai j'ai fait ma carrière à la
Fédération Française de Golf j'étais
directeur des sports donc j'étais
attaché au haut niveau avec le DTN et
j'avais en charge de l'organisation du
sport en France
donc c'est ce que l'on fait au cootidien
ici aussi les compétitions l'index mais
aussi les grands prix les championnats
d'Europe on a organisé les championnats
du monde ici en 1994 dé jeux
méditerranéen enfin ça avait une autre
dimension et après il y a eu une une
logique je dirais de de management
j'avais entre entre 15 et 20 personnes
de management à la Fédération ce poste
s'est libéré il y avait une logique à ce
que un cadre au cadre de la Fédération
fédération soit transféré pour donner et
aider les ambitions et nourrir les
ambitions du Golf National à répondre à
un Open de haut niveau et aussi à la
candidature de la Raider Cup mais en soi
pour être honnête c'était
pas c'était pas un objectif ou une
ambition d'être directeur de golf mais
ça me plaitt beaucoup oui oui c'est en
plus voilà avec les événements qui qui
vont arriver euh évidemment la rider Cup
on aura l'occasion d'en parler parce que
c'est 2018 mais il va y avoir des des
conséquen de ça notamment alors il y a
souvent ça fait très longtemps qu'on dit
ça le golf c'est un sport de de riche
c'est un sport de privilégié euh parfis
un sport de vieux aussi enfin voilà il y
a beaucoup de choses he a beaucoup de
chos beaucoup d'images c'est vrai que là
vous faites aussi vous un très gros
effort justement pour attirer euh bah
des des gens des enfants notamment de
classe sociale qui sont pas forc des
class sociale favorisé à ce sport ouais
il y a il y a beaucoup de programmes qui
sont développés le premier programme
c'est d'avoir un tarif public h quel
qu'il soit et un tarif pour les
licenciés remisés et fortement remisés
l'objectif c'est évidemment de
rentabiliser ce golf mais comme tout le
monde
euh mais de donner la possibilité au
licenciés de réellement pouvoir jouer
l'albatrose qui a un parcours
d'excellence mais tous les autres
parcours d'avoir un peu l'impression
d'être chez eux
en parce que très très sincèrement ça
leur appartient dans dans dans le fond
même si c'est l'outil de la Fédération
la Fédération vit à 80 % avec l'argent
des licenciés don de la licence donc il
y a une logique à tout ça derrière c'est
vrai qu'on a progr on a on a développé
d'autres programmes qui sont à
l'initiation à l'enseignement avec des
initiations gratuites toutes les
semaines donc des gens peuvent venir
découvrir gratuitement le golf il y a le
programme évidemment fédéral de tous au
golf ou pendant une semaine on peut
découvrir le golf et avec l'école de
golf on a développé effectivement un
programme qui s'appelle
crocoolfocf voà avec la Fondation René
Lacoste et on aide voilà alors on aide
des enfants du Secours populaire mais
pas qu'à faire du golf c'estàd qu'on
essaie vraiment d'y mettre une dimension
de vie éducative et sur le long terme
c'estàd qu'on a commencé il y a 4 ans on
va aller au moins jusqu'à la rider Cup
c'està-dire il y a 6 ans supplémentaires
donc c'est sur 10 ans l'objectif c'est
pas de dire on vous paye du golf essayer
de jouer au golf c'est un art de vivre
on essaie de leur présenter nos métiers
donc on leur donne également la
possibilité de de de rencontrer le
personnel de golf pour peut-être bah
donner des ambitions à certains de se
dire bah oui pourquoi pas tiens je
pourrais être enseignant de golf tiens
je pourrais travailler sur un golf on
essaie vraiment de donner d'autres
valeurs on reçoit les enfants on leur
parle on fait beaucoup de choses il y a
pas que la dimension golf alors on a
beaucoup calqué ça sur la sur le
l'association fait le mur de Yannick Noa
donc c'est le même reregistre mais sur
le golf avec d'autres valeurs he
évidemment que du tennis mais le
principe il est là aider des enfants
sortir des enfant du quotidien leur
donner la chance de parcourir des des
des des des parcours de golf c'est pas
donné à tout le monde dans ce cadre ici
le Golf National c'est donne résultat
parce qu'il y a des et ça donne des
résultats ouais c'est vraiment ouais des
petits jeunes qui commencent à bien
taper la balle qui réclam à leurs
parents envers et contre tout même quand
il pleut d'aller au golf le samedi de
retrouver leurs copains et on est fier
d'amener de leur amener ces valeurs là
après on verra l'avenir mais déjà on a
réussi notre premier Paris qui était de
leur montrer que le golf c'est pas que
ce qu'on imagine effectivement ces
images images voilà même si euh le golf
est peut-être plus onéreux que de faire
du vélo mais ça reste très raisonnable
et encore le vélo de course
effectivement c'est cher effectivement
euh la rider Cup c'est dans c'est dans 6
ans hein vous espérez vous serez quoi
dans 6 ans vous avez ah c'est c'est la
rider c'est dans 6 ans pour le
spectateur ou pour nous pour nous c'est
aujourd'hui pour moi c'est aujourd'hui
c'est vous Espérit toujours être là et
toujours être à ce poste là ou un autre
poste toujours à la fédération en tout
cas oui
aujourd'hui la question se pose pas dans
le sens où on a des beaux projets et je
pense que ce genre de métier amène à des
opportunités la question de se poser on
répond aux opportunités où on croit au
projets que que l'on mène à aujourd'hui
le golf national était un golf qui a été
qui était un petit peu compliqué à gérer
qui a retrouveré ceses ces lettes de
noblesse dans tous les sens du terme
tant pour les licenciés tant pour le
haut niveau tant pour les professionnels
il y a le projet de la rider Cup c'est
quelque chose que il y a pas directeur
au monde qui peut se dire je vais aller
voir ailleurs je vais aller voir
ailleurs maintenant peut-être que si
j'ai un autre projet bah j'irai voir
ailleurs on n' sait rien à aujourd'hui
pour l'instant vous êtes mon cadre de
vie il est ici on est à pleintemps mais
il y a aussi les Jeux
Olympiques la France et Paris la France
et Paris seront forcément candidats
alors on parle de 2024 2024 c'est que 6
ans après que 2018 ça réfléchit oui ça
non mais ça laisse ça laisse des projet
al quand on parle de projet comme la
rider Cup qui le trè événement
s on parle des jeux Olympi c'est desjets
qui et qui séduisent en ver et contre
vous vivez dans le rêve formable c'est
exactement ça merci infiniment a grand
plaisir merci d'être venu
[Musique]
merci
I